let me ask you just on this tension
we've been dancing between physics and
Mathematics
um what to you is an interesting line
you can draw between the two uh you have
done some very complicated mathematics
in your life to explore the laws of
nature what's the difference between
physics and Mathematics
to you well um
um I love math I think my first love is
is physics and the math that I've done
I've
I've drawn to because it was needed and
serve as a physics in service of physics
but then of course in the
In the Heat of it it has its own appeal
and uh In the Heat of it I like it sure
it has its so it's its own appeal and I
certainly enjoyed it and
ultimately I would like to think I
wouldn't say I believe
but I would like like to think that
there's no difference between physics
and Mathematics that
or mathematics
is realized in the physical world and
all physics has a for a mathematical
basis that they're really the same thing
I mean why would there be math that had
no physical
manifestation it seems a little odd
right you have two kinds of math some
that
are relevant to the real world where
they don't have to be contradictory but
you can have a can't you not have
mathematical objects that are not at all
connected to the physical world so I
mean this is to the question of is math
discovered or invented
I said to you math is just discovered
and and and there's a deep linkage
between the two yeah yeah yeah uh do you
find it all compelling these ideas uh
like something like Max tegmark where
our universe is actually fundamentally a
mathematical object
that math is our universe is
mathematical fundamentally mathematical
in nature
my expertise is a a physicist doesn't
add anything to that
um
it's not really you know physics is
you know I was once very interested in
philosophy and
you know physics
physics
I like questions that can be answered
that it's not obvious what the answer is
and that you can find a
an answer to the question
and everybody will agree
what the answer is and that there's a an
algorithm for for getting there
um not that these other questions aren't
interesting
um and they don't somehow have a way of
preventing presenting themselves but to
me the interesting thing is to
is is motion in what we know is learning
more and understanding things that we
didn't understanding before things that
seemed totally confusing having them
seem obvious that's wonderful so
I think that's those questions are there
I mean I would
even go further you know the whole
Multiverse I don't
I don't think there's too much we
concrete we're ever going to be able to
say about it this this is fascinating
because you spend so much time in string
theory which is devoid from a connection
to the physical world for a long time
like it did not devoid but it it it
travels in a mathematical world that
seems to be beautiful and consistent and
seems to indicate that it could be a a
good model of the laws of nature but
there's it's still traveling
independently because it's very
difficult to experimentally verify but
there's a promise Laden in it in the
same way Multiverse or uh you could have
a lot of kind of very far out there
questions where your gut and Instinct
and intuition says that maybe in 1500
200 years you'll be able to actually
have strong experimental validation
right
I think that with string theory
um
I don't think it's likely that we could
measure it
but we could get lucky
in other words just to take an example
about 10 or 20 years ago it was thought
that they had seen a string in the sky
and it that it was seen by
um
you know doubled stars that were
gravitationally lensed around the
gravitational field produced by some
long string there was a line of double
instant now the signal went away okay
but
people were hoping that they'd seen a
string and could be a fundamental string
that it somehow gotten stretched and
that would be some evidence for string
theory there was also bicep two
which
it was a the experiment was wrong
but it could have happened
it could have happened that we got lucky
and this experiment was able to make
direct measurements certainly would have
been measurements of quantum gravity if
not string theory
so it's a logical it's a very logical
possibility that we could get
experimental evidence from strength that
is a very different thing than saying do
this experiment here's a billion dollars
and after you do it we'll know whether
or not strings are real
but I think it's a crucial difference
it's measurable in principle
and we don't see how to get
from here to there
if we see how to get from here to there
in my eyes it's boring
right so when I was a graduate student
they knew how to measure the Higgs boson
took 40 years
but
they did it
I not just say that stuff is boring I
don't want to say that stuff yeah but I
I you know you know would Magellan set
out
he didn't know we could get around the
world
there was no map you know so I don't
know how we're gonna
um
thank you connect in a concrete way
all these ideas of string theory to the
real world and you know when I started
out in graduate school I said what is
the what is the most interesting problem
that there might be the deepest most
interesting problem that there might be
progress on in 60 years
and
I think it could be you know uh that you
know in another 30 years that maybe
we'll learn that uh we have understood
how black holes store information you
know that doesn't seem wild that that
we're able to abstract what we learned
from string theory and show that it's
operative and and and and and you know I
mean the Bose Einstein condensate they
did you know they if you win Bose and
Einstein
uh predicted it when was that the 30s
maybe early 30s
it took they were there were 20 orders
of magnitude that were needed
in order to Improvement in order to
measure it
um and they did
50 years later
so and then you couldn't have guessed
how that had happened how they could
have gotten that
and it could happen that we I don't
think we're gonna light
see the heterotic string Spectrum at an
accelerator but but it could be that
things come around and and uh
in an interesting way and
somehow it comes together and the fact
that we can't see to the end
isn't a reason not to do it you know we
just you know what did they do when they
were trying to find the specific right
they just they took every route they
just tried everything and that's what
we're doing and we're taking and I'm
taking the one that my nose tells me is
the best you know and other people are
taking other ones and that's good
because we need every
every person taking every route
and you know if somebody on another
route
uh
find something that looks really
promising you know I'm gonna make a
Portage over the mountain and get on
their stream you know so the fact that
you don't
see the experiment Now isn't to me a
reason to give up on what I view as the
most fundamental
Paradox in 20th century
20th in present physics 20 21st century
physics absolutely you can see that it's
possible you just don't know the way but
that's what I mean why some of the
philosophical questions could be
formulated in a way that's explorable
scientifically so uh some of the stuff
we've talked about but you know for
example this topic that's become more
okay to talk about which is the topic of
consciousness
uh you know to me as an artificial
intelligence person that's a very
practically interesting topic but
there's also philosophers uh Sean
Carroll loves to argue against them but
there's the philosophers they're pen
psychists I'm not against philosophers
it's just not as fun I don't it's not
fun right
but they they uh they start a little
flame of a fire going that some of those
Flames I think eventually become physics
So eventually it becomes something that
we can really like having them around is
really important because you'll discover
something by modeling and exploring
black holes it's really weird and having
these ideas around like the ideas of pan
psychists that Consciousness could be a
fundamental force of nature just even
having that crazy idea swimming around
in the background could really spark
something where
that you were missing something
completely
and it's just that's where the
philosophy done right I think
um is very useful that's where even the
you know these thought experiments which
is very fun and sort of the the tech
sci-fi world that we live in a
simulation uh that you know taking a
perspective of the universe as a as a
computer as a as a computational system
that process information which is a
pretty intuitive notion but you can just
even reframing it that way for yourself
could really open up some different way
of thinking could be and then you have
I don't know if you're familiar with
Stephen wolfram's work of like cellular
atom and complexity yeah I did a podcast
with Stephen Hey Stephen that's awesome
I I to me forget physics to get all that
uh cellular automata
make no sense they're so beautiful
they're so like they're from simple
rules you can create complexity I I just
don't think you know he wrote a book A
New Kind of Science
um
basically hinting at which a lot of
people offended as like we don't have a
good way to talk about these objects we
don't we can't figure out what is
happening here these simple these
trivial rules can create incredible
complexity uh he's totally right about
that yeah
and I and physicists I guess don't have
don't know what to do with that
don't know what to do with cellular
automata because you can describe the
simple rules that will govern the system
or how complexity it can emerge like
incredible complexity yeah
of course wolfram's version of that is
that physicists will never be able to
describe it right yeah exactly he tries
to prove that it's impossible what do
you make of that what do you what do you
uh what do you make about the tension of
being a physicist and potentially not
being able to it's like uh Freud or
somebody that maybe uh Sigmund Freud
maybe you'll never be able to actually
describe the human psyche is that a
possibility for you that you will never
be able to get to the core fundamental
description of the laws of nature
yeah so I had this conversation with
Weinberg
yeah how'd it go
so Weinberg has this book called dreams
of a final Theory yeah
and I had this conversation with him I
said
why do you think
um there's ever going to be a final
Theory why should there ever be a final
Theory I mean what does that mean the
physics departments shut down we've
solved everything
um and you know what is it doesn't it
seem that every time we answer some old
questions we'll
we'll just find new ones and that it
will just keep going on forever and ever
and he said well
that's what they used to say about the
Nile they were never going to find the
end
and one day they found it yeah so I
don't I don't know
um
String Theory doesn't
String Theory doesn't look like a
candidate to me for a final Theory it
as it stands now it doesn't get to the
bottom of the world
yeah it seems to me that even if we kind
of solved it and we've
did experiments there still would be
more questions like why are there four
dimensions instead of six it doesn't
seem to have any anything that in it
that would explain that you could you
can always hope you know that there's
something that we don't know about
string theory that we'll explain it but
but it but it still doesn't look like
it's going to answer every question
and um
why is there one time not two you know
why is this but you know it doesn't seem
like it's
I don't even know what it would mean to
answer every question but to answer
every question obviously so when you
refer to The Theory of Everything
you'll be able to have a
if it exists
it would be a theory that allows you to
predict precisely
the the behavior of objects in the
universe and their their movement right
what what about them their movement
yeah like like precisely no matter the
option right that's true so so that
would be a really interesting State of
Affairs
if we could predict everything
but not necessarily understand
everything
so for example
let's just forget about gravity I mean
we're not too far from that situation
if we forget about gravity the standard
model
in principle given a big enough computer
predicts almost everything
but
if you look at the standard model it's
kind of a laundry list with neutrino
masses and all that stuff there there
are hundreds of free parameters where do
they come from
is there an organizing principle
is there some further unification sure
so so being able to predict
uh everything is not the only goal that
physicists have
so on the way to trying to predict
you're trying to understand that's
actually probably the goal is to
understand yeah
but but but right we're more interested
in understanding than actually
that actually doing the predictions but
the predictions are more
focusing on how to make predictions is a
good way to
improve your understanding because you
know you've understood it if you could
do the predictions yeah one of the
interesting
things that might come to a head with is
our artificial intelligence there's an
increasing use of AI in in physics we
might live in a world where AI would be
able to predict perfectly what's
happening and so that will as physicists
you'll have to come to to the fact that
you're actually not that interested in
prediction
I mean it's very useful but you're
interested in really understanding the
Deep laws of nature versus a perfect
predictor yeah like uh you want to play
jazz even within AI yeah AI people are
trying to understand
what it is that the AI Bots have learned
in order to
produce whatever they produce for sure
but you still don't understand deeply
especially because they're getting
you know uh especially language models
if you're paying attention uh the
systems that are able to generate text
they're able to have conversations Chad
GPT is the recent manifestation of that
they're they just seem to know
everything
they're trained on the internet they
seem to be very very good at uh
something that looks like reasoning
they're able to generate you can ask
them questions they can answer questions
it just feels like this thing is
intelligent right uh and I could just
see that being possible with physics you
ask any kind of physical question and
it'll be able to very precise about a
particular star system or a particular
black hole you'll say well these are the
numbers it's it'll perfectly predict
uh and then sure you can understand
uh how the neural network is the
architecture structured actually for
most of them now they're very simple you
can understand what data is trained on
huge amount of data you're giving it a
huge amount of data from a very nice
telescope or something
and then but it it seems to predict
everything perfectly you know how a
banana Falls when you throw it like
everything is perfectly predicted you
still don't have a deep understanding of
what governs the whole thing
um
and maybe you can ask it a question
it'll be some kind of Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy type answer uh that you
know it's a funny world uh we live in of
course it's also possible that there's
no such deep simple governing laws of
nature
behind the whole thing I mean you
there's something in US humans it's
possible that wants it there to be yeah
it doesn't have to be right right I do
what's where do you again you're betting
the for you already bet the farm but if
you were to have a second Farm
do you think there is a theory of
everything that we might get at so
um simple laws that come in the whole
thing
I don't I don't
I I honestly I I don't know but I'm
pretty confident that if there is
we won't get to it in my lifetime
I don't think we're near it but it
doesn't feel like they're like the fact
that we have the laws we do they're
relatively simple already
that's kind of incredible it's just
there seems to be there seems to be
simple laws that govern things right by
Theory of Everything you mean Theory a
theory of
of everything an algorithm to predict
everything
but a simple algorithm
a relatively simple algorithm to predict
everything
so for me it would be a sad day
if we arrived at that
without answering some deeper questions
sure of course it definitely is that but
the question yes
but one of the questions before we
arrive there we can ask does such a
destination even exist so because the
asking the question and the possible
answers and the process of trying to
answer that question is in itself super
interesting because is is it even
possible to get there well there's an
equals mc squared type of there's a
function okay you can have many
parameters but
a finite number parameter function that
can predict a lot of things about our
universe well okay but just to sort of
throw one thing in in order to answer
every question
we would need a theory of the origin of
the universe right
and that is a huge
uh task right so and the fact that the
Universe seems to have a beginning
defies everything we know and love right
because we you know one of the one of
the
basic principles the physics is
determinism that the past follows from
the
the present follows from the past
the future follows from the president so
on
but
if you have the origin of the universe
if you have a big bang that means before
that there was nothing
and you can't have a theory in which
something Falls from nothing
so somehow sounds like you don't like
singularities
well I thought for somebody that works
with black holes you'll get used to them
by now no no I I like this because it's
it's so hard to understand
I like it because it's hard to
understand but but it's really
challenging us it's not a I don't think
we're close to solving that problem so
even uh
and string theory string theory has
basically had nothing there's been
almost nothing interesting said about
that
in the last
many decades so String Theory hasn't
really looked at the big bang it hasn't
really tried to get to the origin not
not successfully not not in there there
aren't compelling papers that lots of
people have read that that people have
taken it up and tried to go at it but
but there aren't there aren't there
aren't compelling
String Theory doesn't seem to
have a trick that
that helps us with that puzzle do you
think we'll be able to sneak up to the
the origin of the universe like reverse
engineer it from experimental from
theoretical perspective like okay if if
we can what would be you've already
gotten yourself in trouble really
because you use the word reverse
engineer
sure so if you're going to reverse
engineer that means you know you you
forward engineering means that you take
the present and term in the future
reverse engineering means that you take
the present and determine the past yeah
but estimate the best but yes sure but
but but if the past was nothing how are
you ever gonna reverse engineer to
nothing
well that's hard to do run up against
the nothing right until they have
mathematical models that break down
nicely to where you can actually start
to infer things
foreign
but it is people try to do things like
that yeah but have not succeeded it's
not it's not something that we we you
know we're getting a pluses in sure
let's pretend we live in a world where
in a hundred years we have an answer to
that
yeah what would that answer look like
who what department is that from
What fields left led us there what uh uh
not what feels what set of ideas and
theoretical physics
um is it experimental is it theoretical
like what can you imagine possibly could
have possibly lead us there is it
through gravitational waves and some
kind of observations there is the
investigation of black holes is it
simulation of universes is it uh
maybe you start creating black holes
somehow I don't I don't know uh
maybe some kind of high energy physics
type of experiments
well
I have some late night ideas about that
that aren't really ready for Prime okay
sure but you have some ideas yeah yeah
but but the but
um and many people do it could be that
some of the advances in Quantum
information Theory are important in in
that they
kind of go beyond taking Quantum systems
and just replicating themselves but
combining them with others